ce n'est qu'une question de jours la
cadence devrait s'accélérer au
vaccinodromes de saint quentin en
yvelines à l'heure actuelle le vélodrome
nationale a réduit la voilure par
rapport à ces derniers mois avec
l'annoncé d'une troisième dose pour
conserver le pass sanitaires les
demandes affluent pour se faire vacciner
une réadaptation est nécessaire il ya
trois chances sur quatre pour que bien
sûr qu'on leur ait armes dans les délais
les plus des ans y prépare mais tant
qu'on n'a pas eu l'autorisation mais si
on ne le fait pas on peut faire 25000
vaccination par parrot semaine et dire
voyez à près de 100000 part par mois
ouvert du lundi au vendredi de 9h à 15h
près de 600 vaccination sont réalisés
chaque jour au vélodrome nationale
vendredi dernier lendemain des annonces
du ministre de la santé ce seuil a été
dépassé depuis les annonces du
gouvernement nous travaillons à
différentes hypothèses différents
scénarios pour accroître notre capacité
vaccinale pour la doubler la tripler ou
la quadruples est une hypothèse en
discussion permettrait de réaliser 1200
vaccins par jour et la possibilité de
rouvrir l'air central du vélodrome est
en discussion avec une préparation
nécessaire en termes de personnel entre
les médecins les infirmiers les
personnels administratifs et d'accueil
et donc il nous faut recruter rapidement
le double ou le triple de collaborateurs
pour accroître notre capacité des rendez
vous en ligne pour la vaccination sont
ajoutées chaque jour pour le lendemain